[Música]
y empezamos las noticias económicas para
eso me acompaña nuestro colega luis
méndez luis bienvenido gracias y
empecemos hablando en eeuu porque la
reserva federal tomó una decisión
histórica al incrementar la tasa de
interés cuéntenos de qué se trata se
trata pues de uno de los de las tantas
medidas que está tomando la reserva
federal para combatir la inflación con
ellos disminuir la liquidez que se
inyectó en medio de la pandemia y que
generó un alto consumo para reactivar la
economía en aquel entonces por supuesto
ahora se quiere que el ciudadano ahorre
para así poder controlar el alza de
precios el alza anunciada este 4 de mayo
por dieron power fue de 50 puntos pases
el doble que la presentada en marzo de
este año cuando por primera vez se subió
la tasa de interés en los últimos años
siendo este el de hoy el aumento más
elevado en los últimos 22 y que la ubica
en un rango entre
0.75 y el 1 por ciento aunque éste era
esperado tanto por los analistas como
por los mercados por su parte llega un
power disipó la duda hace que este
incremento podría generar una recesión
escuchemos si la inflación es demasiado
alta y entendemos las dificultades que
esto está causando y nos estamos
moviendo rápidamente para reducirla
es una economía fuerte nada sugiere que
se acerca o sea vulnerable a una
recesión
louis y explíquenos qué implicaciones
tiene este aumento en la tasa de interés
para los ciudadanos de a pie como ya lo
hemos dicho hay mucha liquidez y lo que
quiere la reserva federal es disminuir
el consumo por ello los ciudadanos
pagarán intereses más altos en sus
créditos pero para profundizar más en
este tema temprano conversamos con luís
gonzález asesor financiero y esto fue lo
que nos dijo
para el ciudadano promedio tiene varias
implicaciones la primera es obviamente
es que el crédito se encarece no
empezamos a ver ya en las tasas de
hipotecas no de estar en mínimos
alrededor del 3%
actualmente ya están por encima del 5%
entonces eso va a tender a ralentizar el
consumo vía crédito no recuerden que el
americano promedio lo que hace es ese un
deuda para consumir en ciclos pasados
américas o américa latina
particularmente cualquier mercado
emergente sufría bastante porque tiene
que subir tasas también para que su
moneda no se apreciara tanto esta vez es
un poco distinto algo que el mercado
emergente se está adelantando un mercado
emergente empezó a subir tasas desde
hace tiempo y las tasas de interés no
sólo están subiendo en eeuu porque el
banco central de brasil tomó una
decisión similar lo venía anunciando
nuestro invitado y es algo que vienen
haciendo los encargados de las políticas
monetarias en diversos países de américa
latina pero en el caso de brasil el
incremento fue de un punto porcentual
hasta ubicarlo en el rango de los 12
puntos 75 siendo ésta la décima
que se presenta de manera consecutiva en
la lucha para controlar la inflación que
a nivel interanual se ubicó en 11% y de
américa latina' pasamos a europa porque
el bloque de los 27 no descarta embargar
el petróleo ruso que está pasando por
supuesto que los países siguen
debatiendo pero en este caso en
particular hay que hablar de alemania y
rumanía que dejaron claro que están
optando por un embargo a las
importaciones de petróleo procedentes de
rusia eso quedó claro cuando los
presidentes de estos dos países se
reunieron el día de hoy y ambos
destacaron que respaldarán el embargo
pero eso sí gradual a este petróleo ruso
para los líderes del bloque entre ellos
charles michel presidente del parlamento
europeo el comercio de petróleo y gas
que de rusia nos ha convertido en una
fuente importante de ingresos para ese
gobierno por lo que la presidenta de la
comisión europea ursula von der leyen
pidió a los líderes de los 27 países que
respalden esta nueva ronda de sanciones
escuchemos
seamos claros y easy
no será fácil porque algunos estados
miembros dependen en gran medida del
petróleo ruso pero simplemente debemos
hacerlo así que hoy proponemos prohibir
todo el petróleo ruso en euro con ración
o el complot para el debate en el seno
de la unión europea ha encontrado
posición de hungría y eslovaquia dos
países que dependen en demasía de los
hidrocarburos rusos para su economía
para escuchemos que dijo el ministro de
relaciones exteriores de hungría
hungría sólo podría aceptar esas
sanciones y el transporte de crudo por
oleoductos quedará exento en este caso
se mantendría el suministro energético
de hungría como esto no es así el
paquete no puede ser apoyado
responsablemente estoy atento al fútbol
holandés y ellos bombonas nintzen y
louis y mientras tanto china está
ofreciendo créditos para la producción
de carbón así lo revela el medio global
times de ese país y cercano al gobierno
chino que agrega que las líneas de
crédito también están orientadas al
almacenamiento de la energía de acuerdo
comunicados del banco que es citado por
el medio la línea de crédito estaría por
el orden de los 15.000 millones de
dólares como parte de las medidas que
está tomando el gobierno chino para
salvaguardar el suministro de energía a
medida que aumentan la expectativa
respecto a los suministros mundiales de
carbón bueno los suministros están
cambiando todo el panorama global
gracias luis por este reporte